let's say i'm some type of an investment
bank and i go out there and i buy a
whole bunch of mortgages so right here
are a whole bunch of people's mortgages
and when i say buy a mortgage it means
that the homeowners
who borrowed the money instead of the
money going to the mortgage broker who
the homeowner thinks that they got the
loan from or from the servicer who they
think they're paying the check to since
i now have bought these mortgages i've
essentially become the lender to the
homeowner and so the homeowner's
mortgage payments will now come to will
now come to me the investment bank it
will now come to me the investment bank
so i do this for a bunch of homeowners
right over there but i don't want to be
the end holder of the of the paper i
really want to be an intermediary so
what i do is i set up a special purpose
entity
i set up a special purpose entity which
is really just a corporation that i set
up and i stick all of the mortgages
inside of that special purpose entity so
i stick them all inside of that so now
the special purpose entity is the owner
of the mortgages and the investment bank
at least starting off would own all of
the shares of the special purpose entity
and so the investment bank could then
sell shares it could split the special
purpose entity into a million or 10
million shares and then sell those
shares to investors
it would sell those shares to investors
and these shares would be called
mortgage-backed securities or sometimes
mbs's they're part of a general class
called asset-backed securities because
what's going to happen now is that all
of this money flowing
flowing from homeowners will go to the
mortgages which are now owned by the
special purpose entities so they'll all
end up inside of the special purpose
entities and some of them will default
some of them won't but on average the
special purpose entity will then be able
to pay a dividend or essentially you can
almost view it on interest on to to the
owner of the mortgage-backed security